la mairie de rambouillet transformé en
qg pour la gendarmerie le café lieu de
rencontre entre les personnages c'est le
décor choisi par le romancier gilles
milova série pour l'intrigué de son
thriller la faire aurore s le capitaine
marc desprès le capitaine cédric goût
amer que pourront travailler ici au
premier étage et qui vont s'habilleront
à centraliser toutes les informations
blondel enquête pour attraper le tueur
en série une histoire d'amour entre
grégoire mercier et aurore sarde est
inspiré de la vie privée de l'auteur j
milova série et sa compagne incarnant
ses héros louvre part d'une histoire
vraie lorsque je suis arrivé dans les
aigus c'est la première vue que j'ai
visités avec donc le premier endroit
pour se poser et on arrive 10e et café
de la mairie une atmosphère sombre règne
dans la forêt de rambouillet le tueur en
série rôde dans ces bois pour commettre
ces meurtres
la fiction rattrape la réalité ce livre
il a une partie est réellement une
partie fiction et pour le lecteur c'est
simple il suffit de le dit en juin se
laisser embarquer par l'histoire il y
aura aucun problème
origine de ce livre un faux mail de
séparation reçu par gilles milova série
le 17 juillet 2016
on a subi tous les deux ruptures par
obligation et au final je voulais lui
faire comprendre directement en écrivant
ce livre que je l'attends que je laime
toujours avec eux je suis là le livre
est née une nuit d'angoissé j'ai sorti
le free lors de ma tête en quelques
instants très très rapidement j'ai
commencé à écrire le 31 juillet est
gelée terminée dans la nuit du 16 au 17
août
c'est à dire exactement trente jours
après le
une rupture dans lequel je n'avais pas
cru c'était une réponse symbolique tout
simplement le romancier a entamé une
série de dédicaces dans les lieux d'un
trip du livre il saura notamment le 27
novembre prochain au café de la mairie à
rambouillet